the West is believed that Iran has had a
clandestine nuclear weapons program for
well over a decade the most visible
aspects of that program are its
facilities to enrich uranium the uranium
has to be put into a chemical form that
can be fed into the centrifuges that
process is called conversion uranium
hexafluoride goes into the centrifuges
the centrifuges spin around at a very
high rate and that separates out the
different isotopes of uranium if they
continue that process they will
eventually get highly enriched uranium
in gaseous form that material then has
to be reconverted into solid form once
that is done then the bomb has to be
assembled and that is a very complex
design task if Iran were to operate its
enrichment capability at maximum
potential it could have enough isle
enriched uranium to make a bomb in a few
months there's really no good defense
against a nuclear weapons attack the
flight time for a ballistic missile from
Iran to for example Tel Aviv would be
just a few minutes and it's one of the
reasons why the original acquisition of
nuclear weapons is so objectionable to
the international community